tout de suite c'est la revue de presse
avec vous et hélène frade bien sûr
bonjour hélène un jean pauline à la une
de la presse ce matin l'escaladent au
sri lanka hélène on en parlait dans le
journal à l'instant le sri lanka où la
police a reçu l'ordre de tirer à vue sur
les pillards et les auteurs de violences
d'après le daily mirror les
affrontements d'hier ont fait huit morts
dont deux policiers et près de 200
blessés alors que les manifestants vous
l'avez dit exigent toujours le départ du
président gotabaya rajapaksa qu'on
retrouve à la une dans ce dessin on le
voit lançant un boomerang enflammés sur
les protestataires une arme qui finit
par se retourner contre lui cette
flambée de violence alarme le quotidien
un sri lankais qui presse ce matin les
autorités d'empêcher le pays de plonger
dans l'anarchie
le quotidien fait état également
d'affrontements entre opposants et
partisans du clan rajapaksa qui
l'accusent d'avoir laissé la situation
dégénérer notamment en ne condamnant pas
dès le départ les violences commises
contre les manifestants manifestants
pacifiques le daily mirror voit
néanmoins un signe d'encouragement un
possible signe d'apaisement dans
l'invitation lancée par le président
gotabhaya au chef du plus grand parti
d'opposition pour former un nouveau
gouvernement
à la une également hélène les tensions
de plus en plus forte entre
conservateurs et progressistes aux états
unis depuis les fuites sur la probable
décision de la cour suprême de revenir
sur le droit à l'avortement a selon le
quotidien suisse le temps les démocrates
vont tenter aujourd'hui d'inscrire ce
droit dans la loi fédérale pour empêcher
sa remise en cause au niveau des états
leurs chances d'y parvenir sont
toutefois quasi nul en raison de leur
faible majorité et de l'opposition
massive des républicains au sénat à six
mois des élections de mi-mandat le droit
à voir à l'avortement déchire l'amérique
de commente le dessinateur chapatte avec
ce dessin qui montre la statue de la
liberté brandissant un cintre qui est le
symbole on le sait de l'avortement
clandestin
quand salvador une femme a été condamné
hier à trente ans de prison et l'aisne
pour avoir fait une fausse couche el
país précise que cette femme a passé
deux ans en prison préventive séparée de
sa fille de 7 ans avant d'être en effet
effectivement condamné d'après le
quotidien espagnol qui cite des actions
des associations salvadorienne de
défense du droit à l'avortement cette
femme aurait été en réalité obligé
d'interrompre sa grossesse en raison
d'une urgence sanitaire pour n'avoir pas
reçu en temps en temps et en heure les
soins nécessaires ce qui n'a pas empêché
le bureau du procureur d'engager donc
des poursuites la législation
draconienne du salvador interdit en
effet les vg dans toutes les
circonstances même en cas de danger pour
la santé de la mère ou de l'enfant et la
loi prévoit des peines de prison pouvant
aller jusqu'à 8 ans d'emprisonnement
pour homicide voire 50 ans de prison en
cas de d'homicide aggravé en france une
association a porté plainte auprès de
plusieurs tribunaux aux hellènes pour
protester contre les accouchements sur
le territoire français de mère porteuse
ukrainienne l'association juristes pour
l'enfance estime que ces accouchements
constitue une manière de contourner
l'interdiction de la gestation pour
autrui la gpa et que la guerre en
ukraine sert en réalité deux prétextes
je cite pour permettre l'accouchement en
france de mère porteuse du craignait
n'ayant passé un contrat de gpa avec des
couples français selon l'avocate de cinq
de ces couples cité par le monde ces
plaintes sont toutefois vouée à l'échec
techniquement car pour déposer plainte
il faut être une victime directe ce qui
n'est pas le cas de cette association le
journal indique que l'ukraine est
devenue une destination privilégiée pour
la gpa depuis 2015 depuis que cette
pratique s'est progressivement fermés
aux étrangers en thaïlande et en inde
sans transition aucune un mot sur le
discours du trône prononcé hier par le
prince charles devant le parlement
britannique en l'absence de sa mère
elizabeth ii une première l'absence de
la reine pour raisons de santé une
première en effet en près de 60 ans et
son remplacement par son fils fonds
continue à faire la une de la presse
britannique notamment du sun dégaine
pauline pour l'occasion la une la plus
mièvre du monde j'espère que tu as été
fier de moi maman avec cette photo du
prince charles plus bardés de
décorations car général soviétique je
t'en as regarde tristement pensif à la
couronne maternelle la même photo qu'on
retrouve d'ailleurs à la une de métro
qui tente un jeu de mot assez
intraduisible which you
j'aimerais que tu sois l'héritier où
j'aimerais que tu sois l'avoir jamais
que tu sois elle à chacun sont
interprétés on ne se quittent pas là
dessus elle a de même si c'était pas mal
déjà est la brique trône toujours
quoique dans une toute autre catégorie
d'accord à john fait état du tollé
provoqué par un député canadien qui
s'est fait remonter les bretelles si je
puis dire pour avoir participé à une
réunion virtuelle de la chambre des
communes une réunion sur zoom depuis des
toilettes un comportement perçu comme un
outrage envers le parlement cathédrale
de la démocratie le député concerné a dû
présenter ses plus plates excuses à
l'histoire ne dit pas en revanche s'il a
été envoyé au petit coin merci à l'année
bravo pour la transition c'est ce que
vous attendez impatiemment chaque année
hélène l'événement cathodique qui met
des paillettes dans votre vie c'est